¿Cuántos cracionistas hay aquí esta noche?
Probablemente ninguno. Creo que somos todos darwinistas.
E incluso así, muchos darwinistas están un poco ansiosos, un poco intranquilos.
Quisieran ver los límites del alcance del darwinismo.
Está bien.
¿Las telarañas? Seguro que son producto de la evolución
¿La Red? No estoy tan seguro.
Las presas de los castores sí; la presa Hoover, no.
¿Qué creen que evita que los productos del ingenio humano
sean ellos también fruto del árbol de la vida
y por lo tanto, en algún sentido, obedezcan a las reglas de la evolución?
Pese a ello, las personas son renuentes
a la idea de aplicar las reglas de la evolución al pensamiento -- a nuestro pensamiento.
Así que voy a hablar un poco al respecto,
teniendo presente que hay mucho en el programa.
Imaginad que estáis afuera en un bosque, en algún prado
y veis una hormiga trepando por una brizna de hierba.
Sube hasta arriba y se cae,
y sube y se cae y sube --
tratando de quedarse en la cima de la brizna de hierba.
¿Qué está haciendo esta hormiga? ¿A qué viene todo esto?
¿Qué metas está persiguiendo esta hormiga al subir la brizna de hierba?
¿Qué gana la hormiga?
Y la respuesta es: nada. La hormiga no gana nada.
Entonces, ¿por qué lo hace?
¿Se ha vuelto loca?
Si, precisamente, la han vuelto loca.
Está infectada por un parásito cerebral.
Es un parásito cerebral que necesita llegar al estómago de una oveja o una vaca
para continuar su ciclo vital.
Los salmones nadan contracorriente para desovar
y los parásitos se apropian de una hormiga,
se arrastran hasta su cerebro y la usan como un vehículo todo terreno.
La hormiga no gana nada.
El cerebro de la hormiga ha sido secuestrado por un parásito que infectó su cerebro
y la indujo a un comportamiento suicida.
Deja los pelos de punta.
Bueno, ¿acaso pasa algo similar con los humanos?
¿Hay algo que sea más importante que la preservación de la especie?
Bueno, quizá ya se les haya ocurrido
que la palabra "islam" significa "rendición", "sumisión del interés propio a la voluntad de Alá".
Bueno, son las ideas, no los gusanos, los parásitos que secuestran nuestra mente.
¿Estoy diciendo que una minoría en el mundo
tiene su cerebro secuestrado por ideas parásitas?
Oh, no, es peor que eso.
La mayoría de las personas lo tiene.
(Risas)
Hay muchas ideas por las que morir.
La libertad, si eres de New Hampshire.
(Risas)
La justicia. La verdad. El comunismo.
Muchas personas dieron su vida por el comunismo,
y muchas otras lo hicieron por el capitalismo.
Y muchas por el catolicismo. Y muchas por el islam.
Estas son unas pocas de las ideas por las cuales morir.
Son infecciosas.
Ayer Amory Lovins habló de "repetitis infecciosa".
De hecho, era un término despectivo.
Es una ingeniería sin pensamiento.
Bueno, la mayoría de la divulgación cultural
no es precisamente pensamiento brillante y original,
sino repetitis infecciosa.
Y deberíamos tener una teoría de lo que está pasando.
Así podríamos entender las condiciones de la infección.
Nuestros anfitriones trabajan duro para esparcir estas ideas.
Yo mismo soy un filósofo, y uno de los riesgos del oficio es
que la gente nos pregunta sobre el significado de la vida.
Y tienes que tener un eslogan,
saben, tienes que tener una postura.
Esta es la mía.
El secreto de la felicidad es: encuentra algo más importante que tú
y dedica tu vida a ello.
La mayoría de nosotros -- ahora que la "década del Yo" ha pasado realmente --
hace esto.
Un grupo cualquiera de ideas
sencillamente reemplaza nuestros imperativos biológicos.
Este es nuestro summum bonum.
No es maximizar la cantidad de nietos que uno tiene.
Ahora, esto tiene un profundo efecto biológico:
la subordinación de los intereses genéticos a otros intereses.
Ninguna otra especie hace nada parecido.
Bueno, ¿qué podemos pensar sobre esto?
Por un lado, tiene un efecto biológico, y uno muy grande.
Es innegable.
¿Qué teorías queremos usar para estudiar esto?
Bueno, muchas. ¿Pero cómo las unimos?
La idea de ideas que se duplican;
ideas que se duplican pasando de un cerebro a otro.
Richard Dawkins, a quien escucharán más tarde, inventó el término "meme"
y expuso la primera visión clara y vívida
en su libro "El gen egoísta".
Aquí voy a hablar de su idea.
Bueno, ya ven, ahora no es suya. Sí -- él la empezó.
Pero es una idea de todos ahora.
Y él no es responsable de lo que yo diga acerca de los memes.
Yo soy el responsable de lo que diga acerca de los memes.
De hecho, pienso que todos somos responsables
no solo de los efectos previstos o intencionados de nuestras ideas,
sino también de sus probables malos usos.
Creo que es importante, para Richard y para mí,
que no se abuse de estas ideas ni se usen mal.
Es muy fácil usarlas mal. Por eso son peligrosas.
Es un trabajo muy costoso
el evitar que las personas a quienes asustan estas ideas
las simplifiquen y que las usen para cualquier fin indebido.
Tenemos que seguir muy atentos,
tratando de corregir estas malas interpretaciones,
para que solo las variantes benignas y útiles de nuestras ideas sigan propagándose.
Pero esto es un problema.
No tenemos mucho tiempo, así que voy a seguir un poco con esto y a cortar
porque voy a contar muchas otras cosas.
Así que solo déjenme señalar que los memes son como virus.
Eso es lo que dijo Richard en el 93.
Y pueden pensar, "Bueno, ¿cómo puede ser eso?
Quiero decir, un virus es algo -- ya saben, ¡algo material! ¿De qué está hecho un meme?"
Ayer, Negroponte estaba hablando de la telecomunicación viral,
pero -- ¿qué es un virus?
Un virus es una cadena de ácido nucleico con personalidad.
(Risas)
Quiero decir, tiene algo
que suele hacer que se replique mejor que la competencia.
Y eso es lo que es un meme: un paquete de información con personalidad.
¿De qué están hechos los memes? ¿De qué están hechos los bits, mamá?
De silicio, no.
Están hechos de información, y pueden transportarse en cualquier medio físico.
¿De qué están hechas las palabras?
Algunas veces, cuando la gente dice, "¿Acaso existen los memes?"
Yo digo "Bueno, ¿acaso existen las palabras? ¿Están en tu ontología?"
Si están, las palabras son memes que pueden pronunciarse.
También hay muchos otros memes que no pueden pronunciarse.
Hay diferentes especies de memes.
¿Recuerdan a los shakers? (grupo religioso protestante) ¿El regalo de ser simples?
Solían hacer muebles sencillos y hermosos.
Por supuesto, están prácticamente extintos ahora.
Y una de las razones es que parte de su credo
es que uno debe ser célibe.
No sólo el sacerdote. Todo el mundo.
Bueno, no es tan sorprendente que se extinguieran. (Risas)
Pero de hecho, no es por eso por lo que se extinguieron.
Sobrevivieron tanto como lo hicieron
en una época en la que la seguridad social no existía.
Y había un montón de huérfanos y viudas,
personas así, que necesitaban un hogar de acogida.
Y así tenían un suministro constante de conversos.
Y así podían continuar.
Básicamente podrían haber seguido para siempre.
Con un celibato perfecto por parte de los anfitriones.
La idea se transmitía gracias al proselitismo
en lugar de a través de los genes.
Las ideas pueden sobrevivir independientemente del hecho
de que no se transmitan genéticamente.
Un meme puede prosperar a pesar de tener un impacto negativo en la adaptación genética.
Después de todo, el meme de los shakers era un parásito esterilizador.
Hay otros parásitos que también hacen esto -- que dejan a su hospedador estéril.
Es parte de su plan.
No necesitan tener una mente para tener un plan.
Solo voy a llamar su atención sobre una
de las muchas implicaciones de la perspectiva memética, la cual recomiendo.
No hay tiempo para profundizar en ello.
En el genial libro de Jared Diamond "Armas, gérmenes y acero",
habla de cómo fueron los gérmenes, más que las armas y el acero,
los que conquistaron el nuevo hemisferio -- el hemisferio occidental --,
los que conquistaron el resto del mundo.
Cuando los exploradores y viajeros europeos se expandieron,
trajeron con ellos los gérmenes
contra los que estaban inmunizados,
los que habían aprendido a tolerar a lo largo
de cientos de años, de miles de años
viviendo con animales domésticos que eran la fuente de esos patógenos.
Y sencillamente los arrasaron -- estos patógenos arrasaron a los nativos,
que para nada eran inmunes a ellos.
Y lo estamos haciendo otra vez.
Esta vez lo hacemos con ideas tóxicas.
Ayer, unas cuantas personas -- Nicholas Negroponte y otros --
hablaron de todas las cosas maravillosas
que pasan cuando se esparcen las ideas,
gracias a las nuevas tecnologías, alrededor del mundo.
Y estoy de acuerdo. Es en gran parte maravilloso. En su mayor parte maravilloso.
Pero entre todas esas ideas que inevitablemente circulan por todo el mundo
gracias a nuestra tecnología, hay muchas ideas tóxicas.
Hace un tiempo que nos hemos dado cuenta.
Sayyid Qutb es uno de los padres fundadores del fanatismo islámico,
uno de los ideólogos que inspiraron a Osama Bin Laden.
"Uno sólo tiene que echar un vistazo a sus películas, sus desfiles de moda, sus concursos de belleza,
sus salones de baile, sus bares y sus medios de comunicación". Memes.
Estos memes se están esparciendo por el mundo
y están destruyendo culturas enteras.
Están destruyendo lenguas.
Están destruyendo tradiciones y costumbres.
Y no es nuestra culpa, como tampoco es nuestra culpa cuando nuestros gérmenes
arrasan con todas aquellas personas que no han desarrollado la inmunidad.
Nosotros somos inmunes a toda la basura que está en la periferia de nuestra cultura.
Somos una sociedad libre, así que permitimos la pornografía y esas cosas -- les restamos importancia.
Son como un resfriado leve.
No son un asunto tan serio para nosotros.
Pero debemos reconocer que, para mucha gente en el mundo,
son un asunto muy serio.
Y deberíamos estar alertas.
Mientras esparcimos nuestra educación y nuestra tecnología,
una de las cosas que estamos haciendo es ser los vectores de memes
que son considerados como un peligro por los hospedadores de muchos otros memes,
como una amenaza directa a sus memes favoritos --
los memes por los que ellos morirían.
Ahora bien, ¿cómo podemos distinguir los memes buenos de los memes malos?
Ese no es el problema de la memética.
La memética es moralmente neutra. Y así debe ser.
Este no es lugar para el odio y el enojo.
Si un amigo tuyo hubiera muerto de sida, odiarías el VIH.
Pero la forma de lidiar con ello es haciendo ciencia
y entendiendo cómo se esparce y por qué desde una perspectiva moralmente neutra.
Conocer los hechos.
Entender las implicaciones.
Hay todo el tiempo del mundo para la pasión moral después de conocer los hechos
y de decidir qué es lo mejor que podemos hacer.
Y como con los gérmenes, el truco no es tratar de aniquilarlos.
Nunca vas a lograr aniquilarlos.
Lo que sí puedes hacer es fomentar el desarrollo de la salud pública y cosas así
que van a propiciar la evolución de la avirulencia.
Eso propiciará que se esparzan mutaciones relativamente más benignas
de las variedades más tóxicas del virus.
Ese es todo el tiempo que tengo, así que
muchas gracias por su atención.